ROMAN NURIK: Hello, everybody,
and welcome to Android Design
in Action, our sixth show.
Sixth is actually one of the
hardest word in the English
language to pronounce, which
I just found out.
But Android Design in Action
is a show where we look at
different elements of
Android design.
We usually take a look at
specific applications and how
their user interfaces can be
improved using the elements of
Android design, which are very
well documented on the Android
Design site.
But today, we're going to be
looking at rich notifications
and local video players, as you
can see here in our slide.
Before we get started,
we should
probably introduce ourselves.
As always, my name
is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hi, guys.
Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And Nick Butcher
here in London.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes.
I should mention that Adam and I
are broadcasting live to you
from New York.
So let's get started with
Android Design in Action,
Local Video and Rich
Notification.
What we did today was we didn't
look at any specific
local video players that
were previously
reviewed in the App Clinic.
I believe they're actually
re-doing that due to some sort
of technical difficulties.
But what we did today was,
instead of looking at specific
apps, we came up with an example
app that did some
similar things, but it wasn't
branded in any way.
It's not kind of like
a published app.
We have no intention
of publishing it.
It's really just kind of a "what
if", you know, what if
we were to design a local video
player from scratch.
And we didn't do all
of the screens.
We only did just a few of the
screens, primarily around the
browse experience.
We won't be talking too much
about video playback, because
while you're playing the video,
there's a lot of things
that you can really do.
And we have some examples of
apps that do it really well.
For example, the YouTube
App does a fairly
good job with that.
So if you already starting to
create a local video player or
a video player in general, you
should probably model your
playback screen after something
like YouTube.
But what we did do is look
at browse screens
and things like that.
Before we get started, does
anybody else have any things
to add to the exposition
for the show?
NICK BUTCHER: I'll just say at
the top of the show that,
unfortunately, we don't have a
fancy studio setup this week.
So while the stream quality
might be a little bit lower,
you can get the slides
downloaded later.
So if you're watching this, look
at the description in the
YouTube video, and there
should be a link to get
high-quality slides.
If you can't quite make out all
the visuals, then click
through to that link.
ROMAN NURIK: And we're going
to post the slides in, I
think, like 2,560 by 1,440 or
something resolution, so
you'll get all the little--
NICK BUTCHER: Super
HD or something.
ROMAN NURIK: Super, super, super
HD, 4D, four dimensions.
OK, anyway, so let's jump
into the screens.
So this is our example
local video player.
And wow, I probably could have
taken up more space on the
screen than just that.
But this is our example
video that we have.
This is an example video player
that just, again, local
content, and it shows you
a couple of things.
And basically, the rough
structure of this app is that
you could imagine that you've
categorized your local videos
into different groups
or categories.
We'll show that in a second.
And then you might have a queue
of a local videos that
you plan on watching.
And then you probably want to
have some sort of sense of
what has been recently added,
what are recently looked at
or, whatever has been
added in the device.
So this screen is this kind of
your up next screen, which is
kind of like a dashboard
or home screen.
And we chose here to showcase
the two probably most
important things-- in my
opinion, at least--
for local video playback and for
general media consumption
is what's up next, right?
Either stuff that I've recently
added or stuff that
I've explicitly added
to a queue.
Now, you notice that there are
a couple things you can do
with this queue.
You can first--
uh-oh.
Actually, oh, my mouse
is moving.
That's what it is.
[CHUCKLES]
You can first reorder the queue
items by using this
dragging affordance to the
left of each list item.
This is something that again,
that you could find in the
Google Play Music App within a
playlist to reorder tracks.
And then below the queue,
there's the
recently added list.
And it's not really a
list as it is more
like a set of tiles.
You've seen this several
times in the show.
We use this presentation of
content fairly frequently
because it's very versatile.
It works across different
device sizes.
It works across different aspect
ratios of content.
It's, in general, very,
very versatile.
What I wanted to point out here
is that there's a lot you
can do with this tile area, and
it's going to be really
hard to show here.
Let's see if this works.
So zooming in on my laptop does
not work, unfortunately.
But there's a lot of detail
in these tiles.
If you look at the top right
tile in Recently Added, you
notice that there's a little
status indicator, indicating
that something is
in the queue.
So this is something that--
again, you can use this for
starring or bookmarking or, in
this case, queueing.
It's a good, nice, little,
non-interactive indicator that
this is a special item.
And in this case, it really
means this is
already in your queue.
This is just like you would
see in like Gmail or such.
If something is starred,
it has an
indicator in the playlist.
The other thing is that you
can swipe to dismiss items
from the queue.
So we're not really using a
horizontal swipe for anything
else on this screen.
And even if we were, we'd be
able to still use bezel swipe
to access adjacent
lateral content.
But in this case, a queue is
something that naturally lends
itself to swipe to dismiss.
So you can dismiss items, get
rid of them off of your queue
by just swiping them away.
Before we move on to
other screens,
anything thoughts, guys?
NICK BUTCHER: Personally,
I think
it's a very nice treatment.
I think a problem with a lot of
these video-playing apps is
they seem to concentrate a lot
on the video playback, which
is awesome.
I mean, it's the core utility.
But then they don't make a
huge amount of effort to
follow any design guidelines
for the file
management type tasks.
It seems like there's a lot of
apps like in the early 90s
when everyone was building
Winamp skins.
It's all about the visual bling
and then like having
17,000 different format
playbacks, but then no effort
is being spent on the thing that
actually gets you to into
that presence.
So I really like the
treatment here.
Especially I like the key
management features with the
swipe to dismiss.
I think that really works
very well here.
ADAM KOCH: and I guess I kind of
like how queue is given the
priority here, and it's a sort
of infinitely growing list, so
there can be a ton of
items in your queue.
And then below that, you've got
Recently Added, which may
not be as important, but kind of
nice to browse, and you can
possibly add those items
straight to your queue, which
then gets that mass or
indicator, which we're always
talking about.
ROMAN NURIK: It's actually
very similar to
the People app, too.
In the People app, you have
your Favorites tab.
And in your Favorites tab, you
have the top items, which are
your starred people or your
favorite people, kind of like
your quick dial.
Then below that, in case you
haven't favorited anybody, or
even if you have, it's kind
of like extra content.
It's kind of below the fold.
It's not as important as your
favorites, but your recent or
frequently called people or
frequently contacted people
are also something that
you probably want
to have access to.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, and then if
your queue is getting kind of
short, there's not that many
items in it, then you
instantly can see those recently
added items if you
want to add something
to it, too.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
So let's move on to the next.
Item.
NICK BUTCHER:Definitely
you've mocked it up.
How do you envision the action
of adding something to the
queue from here?
ROMAN NURIK: So, I mean, adding
something to the queue
is a good question.
We haven't really-- again, we
haven't gone into video
playback or video
detail screens.
But I envisage that it will--
is that even a word?
Envisage?
Yeah, I'd imagine that when you
long press any video from
anywhere, you enter
a contextual--
I guess the contextual selection
mode, and they you
can long press multiple
videos.
And then in the contextual
action bar, you can have kind
of In Queue or Add to Queue.
And then on the video playback
screen, by default, you
probably wouldn't show
the action bar.
It would probably be hidden
because you won't have the
full-screen viewing
experience.
But when you touch the screen
once, your status bar, your
action bar, and your video
controls pop up.
And in the action bar, you have
like Add to Queue just in
case you want to-- or maybe
you'd call it like a Watch
Later or something, just in
case you don't like watch
right now, right then.
NICK BUTCHER: Just to take off
one of his points, actually, I
think the contextual action
bar is one of my favorite
Android design paradigms because
it lends itself really
well to handling not only
single selection but
multiselection selection in
quite an elegant way, which I
very much like.
So if you long press on one
video from this Quick VIew,
for example, you can see the
action bar will transform into
options suitable for a single
video, so there might be
different set of options
to support multiples.
But then as you touch to select
more items within the
grid, the action bar can then
refine its selections to just
those actions suitable for
multiple, which is, I think, a
very elegant kind of design
in the way it handles
this sort of thing.
ROMAN NURIK: And the other
thing is just users, in
general, are very accustomed--
or Android users are very
accustomed to using long press
to trigger context menus.
And in our case, I mean, I guess
since Android 3.0, I
guess even 4.0, we've
been using long
press as really selection.
And context, like entering
a selection context and
providing extra actions, is
really kind of a secondary
thing, right?
So first, select the things you
want to act on, and then
see the different options
available to you rather than
long press and immediately
have options or actions
available only on the view
you interacted with.
NICK BUTCHER: Some examples of
that kind of behavior if you
wanted to follow up and look
into that, I think Gallery
does this quite nicely, and
Gmail also does a good job of
this because of multiselection
behavior.
ROMAN NURIK: And then we have a
bunch of open source code in
the iOS, the iOSched project,
the Google I/O 2012 app that
does multiple selection
and single
selection action bullet.
All right, so let's move
onto the next screen.
So let's say you that spinner.
What do you see>
Like I said earlier, like I
mentioned earlier, you have
different categories.
So your up next, or your
queued items would be a
dynamic category that would
be updated constantly.
And then you could categorize
videos into custom categories
like, let's say, family videos
or TEDTalks, since TED
provides, I think, most of
their videos in an open
format, and then maybe cartoon
clips, stuff that you're
working on, things like that.
And then this would be
customizable by you, right?
So maybe this is--
depending on what app
you're building,
this could be folders.
This could just be like tags or
collections, whatever it is.
It's really up to you.
These aer just examples
of using a spinner.
So then once you select one of
the items, let's say, family
videos, you get presented with
a, I guess, detail or the
category detail screen, which
gives you a list of items in
that category that are organized
by some attributes,
so, in this case, the date.
And then when you touch on the
sword or the filter-- or
whatever you want to call it--
action button, you get presented
with different ways
to categorize your content.
So this immediately lets you
apply filtering, apply a
better, more easily consumable
perspective on your videos
rather than seeing an extremely
long stream of all
the different videos you have.
Even in a certain category, you
can immediately filter by
different things like title,
year, or percent viewed.
Actually, percent viewed
is something that you
want to call out.
You can't really see it here.
But in that tile, imagine
that I've seen
already 40% of the video.
Let's say it's like a two-hour
wedding video, right?
And I'm 40% of the way in.
ADAM KOCH: Sounds like
an exciting video.
ROMAN NURIK: So let's say I'm
40% of the way in, right?
I think one of the most
important things to bubble up
is that, hey, you've already
seen 40% of this.
And to finish off watching this
video, there's only like
10 minutes left.
So instead of showing the
full duration of the
video in the tile--
in this case, we've chosen-- and
again, you're not really
going to make this out here,
but there's a little like,
eyeball icon, and it says 72%.
There's about 31 minutes
left or something.
So this is just one example of
one of the things you can
tweak within a tile since
you have lots
of screen real estate.
And like I said before,
I mean, you have
this sorting option.
And from there, you can choose
book or by title, so the
section headers would be like
A, B, C, D, E, F, G, and so
on, year or duration,
things like that.
All right.
And then the last thing on the
screen is the tablet version
since we always like to show at
least one tablet screenshot
for the different things
that we look at.
So in this case, we've
taking a look at that
initial Up Next screen.
We've imagined what it could
look like on a 7-inch tablet,
in this case, a Nexus
7 in landscape.
So what you basically have is
instead of a stacked single
list, you have two
separate columns.
On the left, you have the queue,
and on the right, you
have recently viewed.
And you'll notice that each
of those list items
has just more space.
So for the queue, we've broken
it out into kind of a larger
item, larger thumbnails, same
size text, but different
treatment of text.
And then for the actual tiles,
those, again, should probably
scale to take up exactly 50%
of their list in width and
then maintain the aspect
ratio, right?
So with that extra space, you
can show more of the text,
potentially anything else you
want to show about the video,
like, again, time viewed, or
if people are tagged in it,
you can show that,
things like that.
So that was the last
screenshot.
Before we move on to rich
notifications, any parting
words for I guess local video
in general Adam or Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I like the
treatment of this screen.
I think it's very
nicely balanced.
I think the things you've picked
out there about how the
changes you've made from the
smaller list view to the
larger side-by-side view,
it really calls out
how you want to treat--
having thoughts about ahead of
time how you're going to treat
the different amount of space
rather than just stretching
everything and keeping the same
aspect ratios, but really
kind of optimizing to take
advantage of that extra space.
ADAM KOCH: I had one comment.
If you can skip back just
one screen, I guess.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
ADAM KOCH: What I kind of like
about this is, I guess
depending on the type of video
that you're looking at, the
quartering or sorting
would be important.
So, for example, family videos,
sorting by date or by
year in this case is
fairly important.
One nice thing to add here, and
it might be already out.
I don't what you're imagining,
but sort of a section indexer
or a good way to scroll
up or down.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, scrolling.
ADAM KOCH: So if you had a ton
of different videos, maybe
baby videos or wedding videos,
or anything else, you could
quickly skip up and down and
look at all those videos.
And then if you have maybe
TEDTalks and you're trying to
look for something by title, you
can switch to title and do
the same thing.
So there's a lot of power here
in being able to navigate
through a pretty broad array
of different video types.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and I think
for TED videos, one of things
that I would probably
filter on is
duration or percent viewed.
So, like, I'm going to go
on the train right now.
I have 10 minutes, right?
What can I watch from TED
that's 10 minutes long?
This is something that's really
important to me in
general, is just time.
So not only for local video,
but reading, right?
For articles, you should always
show the rough amount
of time that this will take you
to read, because I know
that I'm on a train, and
I have five minutes.
Or I'm walking to the train.
I probably shouldn't be reading
my phone, but I have
exactly this amount of time.
What can I do in that time?
And I think that giving you the
option to filter by size
or length or duration, or I
guess in the case of percent
viewed, how much you have left,
like three minutes left
in this video.
That's a fairly powerful
way of organizing.
The last thing I'd point out is
that you'd probably make it
sticky, right?
So for family videos, you'd
always do year, or TEDTalks,
you would--
I guess not always, but show
the last sorting that you
applied to that category.
So in the interest of time since
we only have 10 minutes
left, let's go jump into
rich notification.
So, Nick, do you want to talk
about rich notification?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, just also
a little note on the second
one as well.
So we're trying to introduce
some more content into Design
in Action as well
as to just doing
straight-up app redesign.
So we're going to try to
highlight some of the cool,
awesome features that make
Android Android, really.
So this is why we picked rich
notifications today to do a
deep dive into what I think is
one of the more exciting
features in the Jelly
Bean launch.
So Android has always
had a very strong
notification story.
I think it's been one of my
favorite features, that it
unobtrusively lets you know
what's going on without you
having to dive in and out of
applications all the time or
have that obtrusive modal
dialogues, pop-up, say.
It's been one of my favorite
features for a long time.
And what happened in the JB
release is they kind of
supercharged.
They added lots of additional
functionality.
So we're going to take you
through a few examples of what
you can do and how you
might go about
designing for this feature.
So straight ahead, as you can
see, this is a fairly
standard-looking notification,
which we would call a one-unit
sized notification, or 1U in
my photo here, showing the
standard information.
So you have a headline and
a subtext start line.
And what you can do is, by
running a finger down the
notification, you can
then expand it out
to a greater size.
So this is an example
we've taken here.
For an online video streaming
service, which is say you've
just kind of paused or abandoned
playback from
another device or another
computer or laptop or
whatever, and we're taking the
opportunity to then present
the user with an opportunity
to resume exactly
where they left off.
So I think this is hugely
compelling having this
additional still frame calling
out the last moment you got up
to, much more compelling than
just some piece of text
telling you that you can resume,
which I really like.
And right there, there's
an action in the
notification as well.
So as well as providing
information, it provides a
strong call to action to
then go and do this.
And the reason we picked this
video resumption idea was to
highlight another feature of the
new notifications API, is
the ability to have what we're
calling opportunistic
notifications.
That is, by default, your
standard form of notification
will add an icon into the User
Status bar so that they can
see, hey, there's a
message waiting.
Something's happened requiring
your attention.
As of the latest release, you
can now provide a priority to
the notification, one of which
is you can say this is a
minimum priority notification,
in which case the system will
not notify the user
with an icon.
But it's kind of opportunistic
in the sense that if the user
is in the notification tray,
then it will display it to
them anyway.
So another example of this
might be Google Now, for
example, which can let you know
the weather and what it's
going to be like for the
next couple of hours.
But it says, hey, this isn't
super-important information.
I'm going to interrupt the user
and tell him about it.
But should they be in the
notification tray seeing
what's going on, then I'm
going to present this
information to them.
So we've kind of used the power
of this opportunistic
notification combined with--
showing a large image and a
strong call to action to add a
really cool little feature
to our video
streaming service there.
ROMAN NURIK: I would love
this for a Netflix
or a Hulu or something.
I'd love that ability to just
open up the notification chain
and say, actually, I do have a
few minutes right now to watch
the rest of this "Futurama"
episode or something.
Let me just touch that
and jump into it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, one thing I
just want to focus on while
we're talking about this is that
some people might wonder
is this crossing over territory
of what might go
into a widget as compared
to the notification?
I'd say the key being that
time sensitivity, really.
Like I'd say this is the kind of
thing you might want to pop
up and just, say, for 15 or
20 minutes, show this
notification, and if the user
hasn't jumped into it at that
point, then I would probably
remove it.
Because notifications should be
about timely information,
whereas a widget can be more
about just the latest things
that have happened,
more of a digest.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Shall we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Let's.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
next one.
NICK BUTCHER: So we hark back
to one of our previously
visited applications in Design
in Action, and we've had a
look at the London Underground
application, which gives you
information about what's
going on on the tube.
One of the important things to
me, as a Londoner, is if
there's a service interruption,
if I'm going to
have to re-plan my journey
somehow, so that's important
that they show me
a notification.
But rather than having to make
me go into the application and
do something, what we've done
here is if we swipe down on
the notification, we've used
the big text style, which
allows you to provide additional
textual information
in addition to, say,
what's expanded.
So here you have an example of
big text that lets you kind of
let the user know
what's going on.
And I can press it.
I can just swipe it away
and get rid of it.
I don't think the message can
affect me, or I can then click
through to me to the
application.
So yeah, this is an example
of the big text style.
ROMAN NURIK: Another option,
and let's say you have the
ability to do rerouting or
something, and let's say, this
app knows about your trips or
your destination, you can
offer actions here like find an
alternate route, or look at
the full details of-- in this
case, touching it should
probably give you the details
on the error or something.
And then maybe then actions like
look at alternate routes
besides in this case
the circle line.
ADAM KOCH: Cool.
ROMAN NURIK: Lots of
different options.
OK, next notification type.
NICK BUTCHER: So, yeah, those
are two of the built-in styles
that come with the platform,
which you could just say, hey,
I want to show a big image, or I
want to show a larger amount
of text than a normal
notification might.
But with the additional
notifications, you can also
get like a blank canvas and
draw whatever it is your
application wants to do.
So we revisited the TripAdvisor
app, which we took
a look at a couple of weeks
back and envisaged
what they could do.
So here, that scenario we're
envisaging is someone's just
arrived in a new city, and
they've detected this location
change, and we're preemptively
offering them to see what is
going on in the attractions
around them.
So, straight away in the
minimized version, you just
say, well, welcome to London.
It says, see nearby
attractions.
But if we were to swipe down,
we can actually provide a
completely custom layout
within the
notification itself.
So here we're displaying two
tiles, like picking out the
top two near attractions near
the user where they've just
arrived in a new city, which
might be kind of fun.
But yet, really, this is
just a window into your
application.
So you can completely extend
your branding, your look and
feel right into the
notification bar.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and then one
thing you can offer here,
again, as further actions may
be see all, or search for a
specific area.
Like if for some reason the app
accidentally just didn't
get your location right, you
could say, choose a different
location or something
like that.
So providing actions, I mean,
almost always there are
multiple things you can
do on notifications.
Providing extra actions, it's
just a really, really easy way
to provide extra functionality
without much effort.
NICK BUTCHER: It's one of my
favorite functions on Android.
So it means it leads to less
jumping around between
applications.
I no longer have to come and go
in and out, in and out, and
have these context switches
all the time.
With the introduction of rich
notifications, I find myself
processing information and
staying on top of things and
doing quick actions straight
from the notification.
I find it really satisfying.
It makes me feel super
productive and powerful.
So I really encourage designers
and developers to
think about how you can use
this newly expanded
functionality in your apps.
ADAM KOCH: One quick thing I
wanted to mention on the
technical implementation side
is that the support library
has an app called Notification
Compact that allows you to
build these rich notifications,
but also great
for earlier versions
of Android.
So it's definitely recommended
to use that so that you can
start using these immediately
and not worry about
maintaining compatibility for
earlier versions of Android.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, basically,
it lets you not do like
ifbuild.SDK.version.version
codes or whatever.
It lets you avoid all of that.
It just does that for you.
So you don't have to
worry about it.
It stores all the codes.
ADAM KOCH: No excuses.
You're going to start using
them now, you're saying.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
OK.
We're running out of time, so
let's do a quick fly through
Android Design News,
shall we, Roman?
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Android Design News.
We need a drum roll or
a gong or something.
[DRUMMING ON TABLE]
ROMAN NURIK: Thank you.
We actually have Daniel
Them from Memphis.
DANIEL THEM: Hello, Daniel.
ROMAN NURIK: And he's providing
our drum rolls for
this evening--
or, actually, this morning.
So first, very quickly, so
Taylor Ling, who's I guess a
common name that we talk about
on design or in our Design
News segment.
Taylor Ling has come
back and done a
password manager redesign.
So this is kind of like a
re-imagining of a password
manager, basically something
that manages your passwords,
that kind of uses different
techniques like the Google Now
style cards, and Crouton--
which we'll talk about
in a second--
Croutons for messages that
pop up from the top.
And just overall in my opinion,
it's a solid starting
point for a Holo style
password manager.
Moving on.
Holo There.
Nick, do you want to talk
about Holo There?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
This is a Tumblr that's been out
there for a little while,
but we just wanted
to call it out.
So similar to this show, they're
taking applications
and re-imagining them
in a Holo'd style.
So if you're looking for some
inspiration for how you might
implement some Holo look and
feel, then it's a great, great
source for that.
So If this is your blog, then
get in touch on Google+ and
then let us know because we
didn't actually know who to
attribute this to, but keep
up the good work.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Marie strikes again.
Nick, since you just spent
some time with Marie in
Berlin, do you want to talk
about her recent work?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So I've just got back from
Berlin over the weekend where
there was a DevFest going on,
so it was great to hang out
with the Android developers and
hackers over in Berlin,
one of whom was Marie, who is
frustrated with Blogger's
interface and thinks
that it needs a
little bit of a refresh.
So she's taken the slightly
tired Blogger look and feel
and given it fresh Holo
coats of paint.
So I think she's done a very
nice job here of marrying the
branding of Blogger, the quite
strong branding, with Holo.
And not content with just that
one redesign, she's actually
also done a quite in-depth
redesign of the Sixt car
rental application as well,
which I think is much, much
better than the official app.
So I really hope that Sixt is
paying attention and can take
a little look at perhaps
hiring Marie
to make this happen.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
moving on.
Showcase view.
So this is something that's come
up a couple of times in
the App Clinic even.
So let's say there's something,
and i this case I
think, it may not be used in
the best possible way.
But let's say there's something
that's like a very
difficult-to-discover feature,
and it's not necessarily
well-labeled, like some sort
of gesture or something.
Showcase View is a little tool
that'll give you this kind of
blue overlay that you can use as
a one-time Help dialogue or
whatever you want to call
it, help overlay.
So when a user first opens the
app, if there's something
that's very difficult to
discover, then you may
want to show this.
Before you jump in and start
using it, you should read our
design pattern on Help, which
talks about the specific cases
where you should use something
like this.
In general, you should try
avoiding on-screen tutorials
or things, because your
interface should
just explain itself.
And if there's a problem
with labeling,
then do better labeling.
But if you do find an area
where it's a gesture or
something that's super, super,
super important, then you may
want to use Showcase with it.
And Crouton.
Who wants to talk
about Crouton?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
I'll take Crouton.
Crouton is a--
initially I think it came from
a blog post by Mr. Cyril
Mottier, who had some
frustrations with the Android
toast class, which is a way
of giving these transitive
messages that show up after a
little while and disappear.
But some of the limitations of
it were annoying him in that
it wasn't really attached
to an activity.
So if you were to show a toast
message and then switch away
to another activity, the message
may remain and be out
of context.
So he has come up with a
toast-like API for showing
more contextual messages, so you
can have info messages and
error messages and so on
within the flow of the
application.
So he outlined this in a blog
placement, but actually
couldn't read any code.
I think the IP was owned
by his employer.
So Mr. Benjamin Vice, another
Berlin hacker, has taken this
idea and run with it and
open-sourced the Crouton
library, which you can
find on GitHub.
And it's in active development
and getting their
contributions and stars.
And I encourage you to take
a look at it, and it might
provide you a nice
way to get these
contextual in-app messages.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
And is that it?
No, we have one more from
Cyril strikes again.
So this is Polaris.
Cyril released a library called
Polaris, which is built
on top of the Global
Maps add-on.
And it basically gives you
things like a standardized
on-screen My Location buttons,
standardized on-screen Zoom
buttons, and also standardized
on-screen Info bubbles, so
bubbles or balloons or whatever
you want to call them
that pop up above markers
when you touch them.
NICK BUTCHER: So I really like
this for a couple of reasons.
Not only will it make your
developers' lives easier to
implement mapping features,
but for me, it also really
standardizes the interactions,
like to be
very similar to Maps.
Maps is probably one of the
most used apps on Android.
And if you deviate from the
patterns where they're going
to locate new buttons or how
balloons pop up and so on,
then your app's going to
just feel slightly off.
And I think using this Polaris
library will really help in
getting that consistent feel.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
I think that's the last one.
Yeah, that was the last item.
So that was Android Design
in Action for this week.
So I think that's all the time
we have, and we're about three
minutes over.
So sorry about that if you're
running to your meeting, and
you have your laptop or
something, and you're trying
to catch the end of the show.
Sorry about that.
You can now sign off.
As always, thanks again.
My name is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: See you guys.
Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye from London.
Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And catch
you guys next week.
Peace out.